[Musique]
on connait partie s'arrête pas là
ça me fait carrément aux bords du rhône
ouais comment ça va la jambe
balade hors du coup c'était d'abord côté
je relève cependant pas entrer dans ma
vie comme toi mon bâché te préviens mon
ami je ne devais pas comme kassali moi
je suis je sois et côté il ya des
versions l'adorent
je suis handicapé par thébaux était
magnifique
donc je peux aussi vous sur internet non
on m'appelle c'est pas con qu'il y ait
au fond d'la gras jamais sur aucun sujet
n'essayez surtout pas de nous censurer
la télé c'est que la déesse etro astra
que des dagues l'année
je pense qu'en douze ans maintenant
je mens de la galette de ma part ça
[Musique]
désolé madame arrive à aller dans la
place et va également y voit les filets
50 ans en parfait accord extraordinaire
[Musique]
je suis son réalisateur ciel pour faire
des kilomètres pour aller à 2000
[Musique]